ん
普通
はいみなさんこんにちははじめ社長です
入ったわけで久しぶりの側だけでございます
2年前の夏の動画です僕がイギリスに行く前に留学に行きますというのをみんなに言っ
た時に
鯖だけで撮りましたねまあ
イギリス留学を終わって日本に帰ってきて大学生と youtube をいろいろやっ
てきたんですけど僕の中で一つ子新しくしたいことというか僕には
他にもしたいことが何個かありますでまぁ
イギリスの留学でとりあえず英語は身につきましたシャベルがまだそんなできないん
ですよ聞くことは一応
誰が何言ってるかはなんとなく分かります
でえっ僕なんですけど
ちょ将来的にはん
なんかこうもっとビッグなことをしようかなと思ってて
ちょっと
ちょっと youtube でいろんな人が見てくれてるんですけど
ちょっと僕他にもしたいことがありまして今一応僕がしゃべるのは日本語と英語です
ポケパラ2つだけだと
ちょっとパターン
もう足りないなって思っちゃって日本語と英語だけ話せても全ての国の一つを話せる
わけじゃないじゃないですか
なんで僕的にはああ
もうちょっと色んな言葉を覚えてみたいと思っています
誰にも言ってないで本当に突然になるんですけど
ストックイタリア語勉強しようと思ってて
ちょっとあの子の道
まあ youtube とかもいろいろ他にもしたいことあるんですけど僕の中で今
一番したいのはイタリア語の勉強です
パスタピッツァとかねす
イタリア語ちょっと本気で学ぼうと思ってて
しませんあのこの動画を最後に
しばらく動画トップはできません
今日から
イタリアに行って
何年かかるかわからないんですけどしばらくイタリアに行って
イタリア語の勉強しに留学に行ってきます
嘘です嘘です嘘ですよ嘘ですからね
うぞなんですけどもイタリアに行くな事実なんです僕は大学3年生なんですけどもまぁ
留学してて1年間をくれるわけですよなんで僕と同い年だった人たちは今卒業なんで
ちょっと卒業旅行みんなしてるわけですぼくまでその卒業旅行チックな感じでちょっと
イタリアに行ってくるっていうお知らせでござい
ちょっとびっくりしたぁーちょっとがっ
チっぽかった僕は英語英語が好きな英語以外はちょっと学ぶ来ないんで大丈夫ですって
感じなんでちょっとドッキリっぽかった所
しばらく行ってきますしばらくってもそんなねじゃなくてもそんな1ヶ月とかそういう
レベルじゃないんだから曲をいろんな敢行してこれればいいなって感じでちょっと
イタリアに行ってきます旅行ですねまぁこの動画を見るときには僕
人もいたリアーでもう多分ピッツ faster してるんで動画投稿がしばらく
ちょっとお休みになるかの身内って感じですじゃあ決まった時
完璧に決まった的ではじめシャツをイタリアの旅に行ってまいりますんでね
2て来たい